ahora que has visto muchas etiquetas
html el resto de este curso será sobre
css y todo lo que puedes hacer con css
para entusiasmar te que permanezcas
interesado quiero mostrarte uno de los
mejores ejemplos de las cosas que puedes
hacer y este es un sitio llamado psss en
garden puntocom más tarde podrás
revisarlo por ti mismo
css en garden es un sitio simple con
encabezado fondo texto y todas esas
cosas pero lo interesante de esto es que
tiene una galería de diseños de personas
que han tomado exactamente el mismo html
y sólo han cambiado el css para ver qué
tanto pueden cambiarlo con sólo usar css
déjame mostrarte lo aquí hay otro
recuerda este es exactamente el mismo
html que viste en la página anterior la
única diferencia es el css
aquí hay otro no solo se han cambiado
los colores las cosas ahora están en un
orden distinto
este es realmente distinto este luce
como un paisaje urbano con un título que
baja por aquí y aquí hay unos créditos y
las cosas están animadas y todo esto se
hace solo con css
tal vez no es el css que conoces hasta
ahora pero si continúas tendrás todo
esto a la mano
si trabajas suficiente serás capaz de
hacer sitios web hermosos que luzcan
exactamente como tú quieras sigue
adelante